what do you think of ben highlights your
time working for
michael jordan wow
that is so hard the list is so long uh
michael hall of fame
there derek jeter
yankees winning the world series there
[Music]
russell westbrook back-to-back mvps
all-star game
there chris paul rookie here there
working for nike and working for jordan
that's the biggest highlight
but just a moment in time where you
realize that the odds of being in those
moments
i'm a kid from toledo ohio
that the vehicle basketball have taken
me places that my eyes could not even
imagine
a being
[Music]
and i was there
being from toledo ohio i saw a lot of
athletes
that went off the scoop and came home
sometimes after the first semester
and i had aspirations to do something
different
77 when i came in 76 they won
i think six games it was like six and 23
and i didn't know that before i signed
my scholarship so i was like okay
they lose and they lose a lot that's
not a good recipe for me but i knew that
there was an opportunity because we can
turn it around
and we turned around we had a 20-plus
season my first year as a freshman
the simple things that hillsdale made it
special i saw the hillsdale community
rally behind our basketball team and it
was a sporting good
store downtown hillsdale whenever my
shoes got to a point where they got bad
the owner would um make sure he called
the coach and he exchanged my old shoes
for new shoes
i said but every time i put my jersey on
i want to make sure that you remember
who hillsdale college was
when you played us i graduated on a
saturday
and on a sunday after graduation i took
off for la to
try to make it to the next level which
is professional basketball
and i got a call from a squad from
caracas venezuela to come over to
venezuela and play
semi-professional basketball there and i
took that opportunity
in that process i learned that when i
graduated i wanted a job
but i didn't know that there's two
differences there's a job
and then there's a career and as i saw
myself playing ball in venezuela
i had a job but now i want to come back
and focus on a career
it's a different dialogue when you stop
scoring baskets
and no one's cheering anymore then what
do you do
i started off in nike as a sales rep
you're away from your bosses at times
and sometimes when you're away from your
bosses you
have a tendency to want to loaf but if
you want to be successful you had to
drive yourself from within timeline
my wife was eight and a half months
pregnant when i took the job
with nike my oldest son is 25 years old
i'm a very proud father of four boys and
they all play basketball
i think we're good much better than i
was at their age
so but just for the camera yeah i
wouldn't tell them that but yes they are
much better than i was at my age
the 10 years in sales was huge for me
because now working with athletes and
when they compete at the highest level
in their sport and have those great
sport moments
it helps drives the consumer to retail
in the consumer mind we were just a
basketball brand
and so we made that transition from a
basketball brand to a cool
culture style brand to now saying okay
well how do we have the elite of the
elite in this brand but
in athletes you got to stay at that
level and that's where the challenge
began because
like derek for example when you're a
yankee you just there's there's love and
then there's hate
for the yankees in there you got to a
point where it's like i'm we're tired of
seeing the yankees win
it was always challenging for me to try
to identify
who could be that next group of assets
and then
who could be that next group that i
actually can put in front of michael's
saying that
i did my homework what about this young
man what about this young lady
michael was involved in everything that
i did every decision that i made
is totally different talking to someone
that's been in the industry but you're
talking to the one
the best that ever played the game
especially when it comes to basketball
and if i got to be told i was okay with
it
my whole nike 24 and a half years of
experience at nike was amazing
but working for michael there was no day
that was the same i constantly
would remind him that i wouldn't want to
be him for 24 seconds
because of the responsibility of always
having to be on
one thing that i could say in my 13
years with working with him and for him
was there's not a shadow of a doubt
whether or not he cares about me
and not just me my family he's been an
extension
to be invested in everything that i do
and he didn't have to
[Music]
what's next
knowing the ride that i've had through
hillsdale coming out identifying a job
in a career
and then the career that i've had what
can get better
it's just a journey
part of me that is hard for
media soon but i know it's god
[Music]
going from a kid from toledo
seeing the world through a vehicle
basketball
[Music]
i've seen the world
you